as the countdown to mars continues
the perseverance of humanity launching
the next generation of robotic explorers
to the red planet
on july 30th 2020 a united launch
alliance atlas v rocket
lifted off from cape canaveral florida
carrying the next generation of
maris exploration vehicles the
perseverance rover
and the ingenuity helicopter and today
on february 18 2021 if all goes to plan
the two vehicles will land safely on the
martian surface
after their long seven-month journey to
the red planet
only 40 of missions sent to maris have
been successful
and perseverance will have to endure a
vicious and complicated landing sequence
as its creators wait powerless to
intervene
waiting for news of its success back in
pasadena
the perseverance rover is the largest
and heaviest rover
jpl has ever sent to mars heavier than
the curiosity rover by 100 kilograms
and with that extra weight comes a whole
host of new gadgets
this isn't some slightly upgraded
version of the curiosity rover
perseverance is benefiting from almost
10 years of advancement of technology
it's packed with fascinating and novel
technologies
that will form a stepping stone in
humankind's eventual
first steps on the surface of the red
planet
this is the insane engineering of the
perseverance rover
[Music]
perseverance hopefully is now safely on
the ground
where it will live a long illustrious
life on the red planet
we have learned some things from the
curiosity rover
that will hopefully help perseverance
avoid the struggles its predecessor
is experiencing we have made an entire
video
on the struggles of the curiosity rover
wheels and how they've been gradually
falling apart on the harsh
martian surface in the end the engineers
of jbl
did not opt for shape memory alloy
wheels like the ones we discussed in
that video
but simply increase the diameter of the
wheels
decrease their width and increase their
thickness while incorporating sturdier
curved threads that will better resist
crack growth than curiosity's sharp
corner threads
they have also forgone the rectangular
cutouts which imprinted morse code
spelling out the rover's origins in the
rusty dirt of its new home
there is a whole host of new software
upgrades too
like the algorithm that determines when
to open the parachute
in the last mission the parachute simply
deployed when the target speed of 1
450 kilometers per hour was reached
after most of the hypersonic reentry
speed of 21
450 kilometers per hour had been bled
off
for perseverance jpl wanted to increase
the accuracy of their landing
so this time around the chute will open
when it is approaching
the optimal trajectory for the landing
site
it will also be scanning the surface of
the landing site and correlating those
images to its pre-existing map
to allow the sky crane to choose the
best landing site
with minimal obstacles perseverance's
ground navigation systems
have also been significantly upgraded
with its optical sensors
feeding data to a machine learning
vision algorithm
allowing perseverance to find its own
path through the rough terrain of mars
where curiosity had to constantly stop
and start with help from its earthbound
controllers
perseverance is benefiting massively
from the past decade of improvements
in autonomous flight and driving
developed by the drone
and automotive industries this will mean
perseverance will be able to cover
much more ground during its life here in
jessero crater
a massive crater that was once home to a
lake the same size
as lake tahoe you can see the remnants
of this ancient riverbed
and delta spilling into what may have
once been a habitable body of water
it is here that perseverance will scour
for signs of life
before we get into all the gadgets that
we'll use to do this
let's look at how perseverance will
power them the perseverance rover
features the same radio izotope
thermoelectric generator
as the curiosity rover rtgs work by
converting the heat
from the natural decay of radioisotopes
into electricity
it uses a simple principle called the
sebec effect to generate electricity
the seebeck effect essentially allows us
to generate an electric current
through a heat differential as charge
carriers both electrons and electron
holes
will move from hot to cold so if we have
two semiconductors
one would charge carriers in the form of
electrons and one would charge carriers
in the form of holes
a potential difference between the two
semiconductors will form
when a heat gradient is applied this
potential difference
causes a current to flow in the external
circuit
these two semiconductors need to be both
thermally insulating to ensure the heat
gradient
is maximized but also electrically
conductive
to maximize the current these two
material properties are typically linked
copper is both a great electric and heat
conductor
while iron is a poor electric and heat
conductor
having a single material that is a great
electric conductor
and a poor heat conductor is extremely
rare
for this reason two unique materials are
used for the p
and n type semiconductors lead telluride
for the n-type
and an alloy commonly called tags for
the p-type
which is formed from telerinium silver
germanium and antimony
now we just need a consistent heat
source thankfully
radioactive substances generate heat as
they decay
the perseverance rover uses 4.8
kilograms of plutonium dioxide
as its heat source this radioactive
material primarily produces
alpha waves which is essential as this
form of radiation
is most efficiently converted to heat in
a compact space
while plutonium-238 also releases
minimal beta
and gamma radiation decreasing the
weight of shielding
needed to protect the electronics on
board from these more powerful kinds of
ionizing radiation
an essential characteristic for a
lightweight spacecraft
the plutonium-238 is also formable into
a ceramic-like material
that will break into large chunks rather
than being vaporized and spread in the
wind
during a launch failure where it could
be inhaled or introduced into the food
chain
the electricity this unit can provide
will gradually degrade from its maximum
of 110 watts at launch
as its plutonium heart naturally decays
losing half of its energy every 87.9
years
which is much longer than the 138-day
half-life of the early polonium-210
rtg prototypes another advantage of
plutonium-238
for this application this will power all
of the instruments on board
like the moxie which is one of the new
devices i am most excited about
aboard perseverance moxie is a new
oxygen generation device
that will test a vital technology for
any future human mission to meris
you may wonder like i did how is this
different from the oxygen generation
present
in the international space station there
is obviously a limited supply of oxygen
there
why do we need to test this new
technology on mars
when we obviously have a tried and
tested method of creating oxygen
already surely the international space
station
does not really recycle oxygen oxygen is
created on the international space
station
through electrolysis of water this
produces hydrogen and oxygen
the hydrogen is then reacted with carbon
dioxide to form water and methane
the methane is then simply exhausted
into space while the water is fed back
into the system
the international space station requires
regular resupply of water
as we are losing two hydrogen atoms for
every oxygen molecule we create
this is not a closed-loop system and
water is a pretty heavy material to be
shipping to mars
the perseverance rover will test a new
method of oxygen creation
using this device which will use solid
oxide
electrolysis to instead break the
plentiful carbon dioxide
in the martian atmosphere into oxygen
and carbon monoxide
its operation is fairly simple air will
be taken
in through a dust filter by a
specialized pump
designed to be as light and compact as
possible called a scroll pump
scroll pumps are pretty cool they
consist of two spiral scrolls
one stationary and one rotating air is
taken in at the inlet
here and as the secondary scroll rotates
it traps and squeezes air
against the primary stationary scroll
this continues to happen as the volume
between the two scrolls decreases
down the spiral causing an increase in
pressure
in this case it causes the variable
pressure martian air
which is typically about 100 times lower
than earth's atmosphere
and compresses it to match earth's sea
level pressure
these kinds of pumps are lightweight
energy efficient and reliable
making them the perfect air pump for the
perseverance rover
the pump feeds the carbon dioxide rich
air through a cell stack
each stack consists of a catalytic
cathode a solid electrolyte
and an anode as air passes over the
cathode which operates at 800 degrees
celsius
the carbon dioxide is split into carbon
monoxide
and oxygen ions according to this
reaction
the oxygen ion passes through the solid
electrolyte
to the anode where it is oxidized
combining with a second oxygen atom
to form gaseous o2 which is then passed
out of the anode cavity and tested for
purity
moxi can produce 20 grams of oxygen an
hour however the unit will not run
continuously
as it draws too much electricity which
will be needed for another
operation in total the moxie system
needs 168 watts which is actually more
than the 110 watts
the rtg can provide at any one moment
so this operation will need to be
supplemented
by two lithium ion batteries that are
included on board
to make up for the low power rtg
allowing it to store
excess power during downtime this device
is exciting because it is a clear
statement of intent
oxygen is going to be a vital resource
for any future mission
and this is actually a scaled-down
prototype of the full-sized version
nasa eventually wants to send to mars
along with an
empty rocket the full-scale version will
produce about 2 kilograms per hour
which will gradually be stored inside
the awaiting rocket over the course of a
year and a half
providing life-sustaining air for any
future human missions
and the oxidizer needed for the ride
home
the next device which is also depending
on a future
mars mission to complete its purpose is
the core sampling drill
the curiosity rover sampling system
drilled and scooped soil
into this instrument the sam standing
for the sample analysis at mars
the sam is located here on the rover it
contained multiple tools that would be
commonplace in many
earthbound labs a mass spectrometer a
gas chromatograph
and a tunable laser spectrometer each
looking for different signs of life
on mars perseverance has replaced the
space
this unit took up with a totally new
system
the sample caching system the robotic
arm of the rover
features a coring drill which will cut
out cylindrical core samples
from the martian surface once collected
the robot head mates with the drill bit
carousel
where it transfers the bit and the
sample tube into a rotating carousel
that takes it to the belly of the rover
where another robotic arm resides
here a number of operations takes place
first
the arm pulls the sample tube out of the
drill bit and takes
multiple images of it before and after
calculating the volume of the sample
then it stores it in one of the 42 slots
under the belly of the rover
where they will remain until the rover
deposits them in these sample tubes
at a designated caching spot on the
surface of mars
this is where things get really
interesting there are plans to send
another rover
designed by the esa to mars in 2026
this rover will deliver the samples back
to its nasa designed lander
which will load them into a mars ascent
vehicle
blasting the samples into orbit where an
esa
earth returned vehicle will be waiting
for us we are attempting to bring soil
back
from mars with robots if that isn't
insane engineering
i don't know what is and we have barely
scratched the surface of what this rover
is capable of
there is a whole host of new sensors on
board that do not require perseverance
to collect soil
each using different forms of
electromagnetic radiation
to investigate the ground below them the
sherlock instrument
on the robotic head will look for signs
of biosignatures
using roman and luminescence
spectroscopy which both detect molecules
based on how they interact with uv light
it will sit about five centimeters off
the ground
where it will focus its uv laser onto
the soil
and be able to detect chemicals that
would indicate the presence of past life
the rover also has an x-ray imager
called pixel
that will be able to visualize the
texture of the ground below it
looking for tiny variations in geology
that would indicate that microbial life
has altered
its environment while also being able to
detect
chemical compositions by observing the
fluorescence of the target
under x-ray electromagnetic radiation
there are several other sensors like the
ground penetrating radar imager
located at the rear of the rover which
will give us visualizations of the
composition of geology
up to 10 meters under the surface and
possibly even identify
water resources buried below a vital
resource for human missions
these are just some of the sensors on
board and of course
there are the usual high definition
color cameras
that are going to send back amazing
images to earth
and this time we included a microphone
so we'll be able to hear what our future
life on mars
may sound like it may even catch the
whirring of helicopter blades off in the
distance
because by far the most exciting part of
this mission
to me is the ingenuity helicopter after
all
if successful this will be the first
time humans have demonstrated
controlled powered flight on another
planet
powered flight on mars presents many
challenges
the atmosphere is about one percent the
density of earth's
meaning there is less air to push down
to achieve lift
to combat this the propeller blades
which are counter rotating to eliminate
the need for a tail rotor
have to spin much faster than a
traditional helicopter blade
at about 2400 rpm that's about five
times faster than an equal sized rc
helicopter here on earth
to deal with the centrifugal forces that
come with that
the blades need to be made of high
strength carbon composites
these blades also have a much larger
angle of attack
than your run-of-the-mill blade allowing
them to push a larger volume of air
downwards
since this helicopter will detach from
the perseverance rover
it needs its own power source unlike the
planned dragonfly mission to tighten
this helicopter will not have its own
rtg
creating an rtg capable of fitting into
this tiny two kilogram helicopter
is unfeasible instead it features these
solar panels
which will charge six lithium ion
batteries on board
and these in turn will power the motors
and cameras on board
for a max flight time of about 90
seconds
this is simply a technology
demonstration that will hopefully give
nasa
and jpl the information they need to
approve and design
a future flying rover today the 18th of
february
2021 is a historic day that i
and many others will remember fondly for
years to come
i remember exactly where i was and what
i was doing when the curiosity rover
landed
and i remember seeing this man on my
screen a man who subverted my vision of
what an engineer
working on something this advanced was
supposed to look like
babak ferdowsi i could see myself being
in his seat
he was relatable not the white shirt
black tie nerdy figure i had grown up
expecting
i remember because i was a fresh college
graduate struggling to find a job
at a music festival begging the
organizers to put the landing on the big
screens
but just ended up watching the live
stream on my phone in a tent that was
falling apart
i didn't fit the stereotype either today
on the historic landing of curiosity's
younger brother
i released an interview on nebula with
that man that i now
somehow call a friend talking about his
career into jpl
and what it was like becoming famous
literally overnight
that interview is now available ad free
on nebula
along with a whole host of new original
content not available
anywhere else mustard's new original
called the origins of stealth
which details the fascinating history of
the f-117 nighthawk
a three-part trivia game show made by
sam from wendover productions
and featuring yours truly that really
shows how distractible and unserious i
am
in person these videos don't get my
personality across
at all and of course my 9 part logistics
of d-day series
we are constantly adding more original
content
and ad-free versions of our youtube
videos and all of that comes bundled
with curiosity stream
for the low price of just 1479 a year
a little over one dollar a month this is
by far the best way to support this
channel
and get something in return with all of
the amazing award-winning documentaries
on curiosity stream
like this fascinating biography of neil
armstrong's life
narrated by harrison ford and you get
access to all of our original content on
nebula
if you are looking for something else to
watch right now why not watch my
previous video about nasa's weird and
wonderful
oblique wing plane or real sciences
latest video about the insane biology
of ant colonies
you